nou pa soit cinq amendements discussion
commune de 154 madame variait ce pardon
madame raymond depardon
c'est pas grave monsieur le président
cette
cet amendement vise augmenté l'objectif
de vente en vrac définies par le présent
article il reprend ainsi sans filtre la
proposition de la convention citoyenne
qui vise à mettre en place
progressivement une obligation de la
plantation du vrac dans tous les
magasins et la position d'un pourcentage
au central des chocs
nous proposons ainsi les seuils
originaux demandé par les 150 soit 25 %
de la surface des magasins à l'horizon
2023 et 50% à l'horizon 2030
le tout pour les commerces de plus de
300 mètres carrés et non 400 ces
propositions de la convention citoyenne
ne sont pas farfelue elle témoigne de la
prise en compte de nos chances à limiter
à la source nos déchets afin de lutter
contre le suremballage lui même porteur
de surconsommation certes nous partons
de loin car le vrac est aujourd'hui
ultra minoritaire en représentant moins
de 1% des parts de marché hors produits
frais pour autant la demande est très
présente comme en témoignent des progrès
sur chaque année 2 41% seul au réseau
vrac par ailleurs ne renvoyez qu'un
objectif très lointains comme le fait le
présent article puisque l'horizon est
fixé à 2030 nous semble un mauvais signe
envoyé aux centrales qui risque de ne
pas prendre dors et déjà les bonnes
mesures et faire les bons choix pour
cette raison il nous semble important de
fixer à double objectif là l'horizon de
deux ans d'ici 2023 pour éviter éviter
le statu quo et est la plus lointain
pour définir l'objectif de long terme
merci merci chers collègues 1391 1392
parce
g monsieur gilles et je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président oui pour
reprendre
justement cet amendement est ce qu
indique et d'autres collègues
il vise effectivement à être plus
ambitieux concernant le calendrier de
mise en oeuvre de l'obligation de
proposer de la vente en vrac dans les
magasins de plus 400 mètres carrés
l'article 11 donc prévoit au moins 20 %
de la surface de vente au 1er janvier et
2030 ce qui est très tardif
or nous tenons à rappeler que la
convention citoyenne proposé de retenir
25 % en 2000 23 35 % en 2025 50 % en
de plus elle proposait que cette
obligation concerne les magasins de plus
de 300 mètres carrés et non pas de 400
mètres carrés comme le projet de loi le
propose en conséquence il apparaît
nécessaire d'être un peu plus ambitieux
pour se rapprocher davantage des
propositions de la convention citoyenne
tout en restant sur un calendrier
acceptable pour les acteurs économiques
sachant que déjà certaines grandes
surfaces réalisent déjà ce cet objectif
d'amendements cet amendement propose
donc de voter un objectif de 20 % en
2025 et de 30 % en 2030 jours-ci 6392
monsieur le président la ministre un
cher collègue cet amendement c'est le
mouvement de repli il propose également
d'être un peu plus ambitieux concernant
le calendrier envisagé l'article 11
il propose donc cette fois de maintenir
l'objectif de 20% mais de l'atteindre
dès 2025 et non 2000 francs pour 428 le
président longtemps oui merci monsieur
le monsieur le président je voudrais
d'abord me féliciter ça a été rappelé
eric de l'inscription de la définition
judy juridique de la vente en vrac dans
la loi dans la loi hajek et c'était ici
à l'initiative du sénat avec d'audit
d'autres dispositions sur le vrac et
cette avancée nous permet aujourd'hui de
fixer des obligations sur la vente en
vrac c'était à nos objectifs en 10 en
2010 9 mai sujet n'était pas encore
encore mûr deux ans après nous avons des
progrès nous en félicitons cependant les
mesures proposées sur la vente en vrac
dans ce texte reste peu ambitieuse soit
la date est trop loin tel soit le seuil
et rob a imposé aux magasins de plus de
400 mètres carrés des deux dédiés 20 %
de leur surface à la vente en vrac et
sans emballages d'ici 2030 est largement
faisable
surtout si on considère que les étals de
fruits et légumes en vrac répondent déjà
à une bonne partie de cet objectif
nos collègues socialistes à l'instant
propose d'avancer la date où proposons
en lien avec les professionnels réunis
dans le réseau vrac d'augmenter
l'objectif
il faut bien sûr laisser un délai
suffisant pour permettre aux industriels
et aux distributeurs de s'adapter nous
nous rangeons donc derrière la date
fixée de 2030
nana de 2030 permet de mettre en place
des circuits logistiques nécessaires à
la vente en vrac permet aux
distributeurs d'investir dans les
installations et celles nécessaires
soient les silos pour les produits secs
les distributeurs pour les liquides
permet former le personnel
mais une fois ces investissements mis en
place il est envisageable de fixer un
seuil beaucoup plus haut et nous
proposons donc 50%
par ailleurs nous souhaitons par
l'adoption d'une mesure qui pourrait
privilégier la grande distribution au
détriment
des plus petits commerces aussi comme la
convention citoyenne pour le climat nous
proposons la mise en place de la vente
en vrac dans tous les magasins de vente
au détail et ce seuil de 20 % en 2030
nous sommes à la fois opportun est tout
à fait raisonnable
on le sait nos concitoyens nos
concitoyens plébiscitent la vente en
vrac mais beaucoup d'entre eux sont sont
freinées justement par l'absence de
telles surfaces de vente dans leurs
magasins
donc c'est tout l'objet de cet
amendement merci le 1393 monsieur bigot
oui comme vous l'aurez compris nous
tentons de proposer toutes les
configurations possibles pour tenter de
se rapprocher des propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat nous
proposons cette fois-ci de maintenir la
date de 2030 mais de retenir un taux de
25%
si madame an avant rapporteur même le
rapporteur oui la date de 2030 est la
cible de 20 % et été ayant été concertée
avec l'ensemble des acteurs
il ne me semble pas opportun de les
changer de même il ne me semble pas
pertinent d'étendre l'obligation prévue
par l'article 11 au petit commerce pour
ces petits commerces nous avons créé une
commission en commission par dont un
dispositif expérimental afin de trouver
des solutions techniques visant à lever
les barrières qui peuvent aujourd'hui
entraver la vente sans emballage et donc
pour toutes ces raisons là les
amendements 150 4391 1392 428 et 1393 ou
un avis défavorable
c'est même un ministre mais ma vie ma
vie donc je mets au voile amendement 154
avec un double avis défavorable qui est
pour
[Musique]
pendant tout m'a pas dit dans le primat
non mais je me manifeste du coup avant
la mise au vote
simplement je voudrais dire que bien sûr
on va suivre la la la la vie d'ailleurs
et de la commission et de madame la
ministre moi je me pose juste un
quelques éléments de réflexion
premièrement la vente en vrac
aujourd'hui
progress et progresse pourquoi parce
qu'elle est demandée par les
consommateurs donc comme je suis plutôt
dans la réponse au consommateurs je
pense que c'est plutôt par la demande
des consommateurs par le par
l'obligation des magasins qu'on y
arrivera et d'ailleurs les grandes
surfaces qui n'ont rien de
philanthropique développe naturellement
le rayon de vrac puisqu'elle voit bien
qu'une partie du marché est dans le vrac
bon donc d'une façon générale je fais
plus confiance à la responsabilité nos
concitoyens qui me semble être de bonne
de bonnes réflexions
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faudra
faire attention et je m'adresse plus tôt
la madame la ministre
il faudra faire attention parce qu'il
peut y avoir des magasins de surface
supérieure à 400 mètres carrés qui sont
des magasins qui vendent des produits de
grande consommation je pense par exemple
à des produits d'hygiène beauté sur
lequel la vente en vrac au des
drogueries par exemple sur lesquels la
vente en vrac est quand même extrêmement
compliqué parce que le produit peut être
dangereux parce que le produit ne se
prête pas aux dés conditionnement du
vrac simplement voilà drôle dans le dans
le faire il faudra être très attentif à
ne pas mettre de côté à un certain
nombre de nos commerçants merci une
bougie dans dhrontal oui merci d'un
injuste a ajouté un élément parce que
bien sûr que les consommateurs voient
qu'on est dans quel cas il ya une
demande et qu'il faut justement à la
fois répondre à cette demande mais le
rôle du législateur s'est aussi de fixer
le fixer des caps d'aller
d'aller plus loin et que la vraie raison
aussi du vrac c'est bien sûr une demande
du consommateur mais c'est surtout de
limiter les emballages et c'est tout le
sens du récit c'est en tout cas c'est le
sens et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
c'est ce que dans ce texte dans ce texte
là donc je pense qu'il faut pas oublier
oublier l'objectif et j'oserais dire
aussi que sur sur notre amendement
c'était justement de faire très
attention à la distorsion de concurrence
qu'il peut y avoir entre très grandes
surfaces ont toute la grande surface à
400 mètres carrés et les plus les petit
peu plus plus petits plus petit commerce
qui pour certains se sont déjà passés en
vrac donc c'est pas une problématique
particulière mais en tout cas ça
permettait de de répondre à cet assaut
sept problèmes de concurrence
merci chers collègues je me revois donc
154 à kindu l'avis défavorable qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté même votre peau en 1391
même vaty n'est pas adoptée même votre
tour 1392 il n'est pas adoptée même pas
pour 428 il n'est pas adoptée même vote
pour le 3393 il n'est pas adopté trois
amendements diffusion commune de 1067
madame lagarde
il a été déjà largement présentées à la
fois par les remarques de madame prime
assurer certaines catégories de magasins
qui auraient des grandes difficultés à
mettre en place la disposition parce que
les produits qu'ils vendent sont par
nature dangereux ils ne peuvent pas être
commercialisée sous forme de vrac et en
fait il s'agit de venir compléter le
décret qui doit permettre la mise en
application de cet article pour prendre
en compte les spécificités qui en l'état
actuel de la rédaction ne l'était pas
merci madame du mal 218
oui c'était exactement un amendement du
même type
simplement je voudrais attirer
l'attention de la haute assemblée sur le
fait qu'ils aient aussi le sujet pour le
vrac des produits cosmétiques ou parfums
et donc qu'ils connaissent donc un
certain nombre des difficultés par
rapport à la date de 2030 est donc cet
amendement vise aussi à prévoir que le
décret d'application opère une
distinction en fonction des circuits de
distribution et le 1395 monsieur bigot
c'est un amendement de repli dans la
continuité du 1394 il propose de
renvoyer cette fois l'objectif de
diversification de l'offre en vrac que
nous défendons au décret prévu à
l'article 11
merci même la rapporteure en fait sur
ces trois amendements les avis ne sont
pas tout à fait les mêmes
pour l'amendement 1067 rectifié l'avis
est défavorable mais au bénéfice en
réalité de l'amendement 218 rectifié qui
nous semble
être un tout petit peu plus large en
fait en réalité dans sa dans son contenu
donc avis défavorable sur l'eau 1067
rectifié favorable sur l'amendement 218
rectifier et l'avis est défavorable sur
l'amendement 1395 fait ma musique alors
oui exactement
nous préférons la rédaction alors on
nous demande on en fait un retrait des
amendements au profit du 1067 de manas
varde on est sur le même sur les mêmes
principes c'est pas on n'est pas sur des
grosses différences mais la rédaction
proposée pendant la navarre inclut
également la prise en compte des
contraintes sanitaires et de sécurité
liés aux produits ce qui me paraît plus
complet donc voilà pourquoi je préfère
la rédaction 1067 merci même du mal de
118 vous maintenez vous leur tirez donc
218 retirer 2395 aurait retiré aussi
donc on va sur le 1067
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission mais peut-être avoir cette
fois ci de la rapporteure est favorable
du gouvernement qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
on entame trois amendements identiques
le 221
oui monsieur kamalén oui merci monsieur
le président de la ministre madame la
ministre chers collègues
l'article 11 vise à accélérer la vente
en vrac dans les grandes et moyennes
surfaces
si la réduction des déchets d'emballages
ménagers est un objectif que nous
partageons tous la généralisation de la
vente en vrac est une solution
particulièrement contre productive pour
la filière viticole
l'utilisation de verre est essentielle
pour le conditionnement du vin
participants de l'identité du vin la
bouteille et le contenant historique
traditionnel est le mieux adapté à son
vieillissement du point de vue de
logique de la logistique l'installation
de tireuses des liée à la vente en vrac
entraînerait une réduction de l'espace
disponible pour les autres produits
cela causerait une baisse importante du
nombre de références disponibles dans
les rayons et pénaliserait des
producteurs confrontés à cette réduction
enfin la bouteille de verre et de plus
en plus souvent le support des
formations obligatoires tels que il a
dit fier de traçabilité le numéro du lot
et bien sur l'étiquetage qui offrent de
précieux renseignements aux
consommateurs pour toutes ces raisons il
est préférable que le dispositif de 23
cas ce volontaire permettant aux seuls
commerçants qui le souhaiterait
des salles et des tireurs nécessaire à
seulement de nos commercialisation tel
est l'objet du présent amendement qui
vise à exclure les boissons alcoolisées
de l'obligation de la vente en vrac dans
les commerces de vente au détail
merci amendements identiques la 671 oui
monsieur le président je viens compléter
ce que vient de dire henri cabanel par
cet amendement qui vise à prendre en
compte les spécificités du secteur des
boissons alcoolisées peu compatibles ou
même pas compatible avec la vente en
vrac
en excluant les produits visés aux
articles 4 102 bis 403 438 et 520 à des
code général des impôts relative
relative pardon aux taxes de droit de
consommation de la proportion de ventes
en vague prévue au 1 de l'article 11
merci chers collègues le 676 monsieur
gilles et oui merci monsieur le
président sans vouloir alourdir donc nos
échanges
effectivement cet amendement vise à
exclure
aujourd'hui la vente en vrac concernant
les boissons alcoolisées madame la
ministre l'avait souligné par ailleurs
on voit bien que sur différentes
productions
il ya quand même aujourd'hui à la
nécessité d'approfondir les orientations
que nous pouvons partager mais qui pose
effectivement un certain nombre de
questions
la notion de traçabilité notamment a été
mise en avant c'est une notion
particulièrement importante pour le
suivi de ces produits effectivement
alimentaire et puis le fait que
l'étiquette a quand même pour nombre de
produits alcoolisés une importance
particulière
il faut veiller aujourd'hui à ce que
cette capacité de vente soit
effectivement préserver donc en
conséquence l'objet de notre amendement
comme ceux de notre collègue de nos
collègues donc d'exclure l'obligation du
vrac pour les surfaces de vente
consacrée aux boissons alcoolisées jour
merci
simard à porter à la main nous venons de
voter fin vous venez de voter mesdames
et messieurs et sénatrices et sénateurs
un amendement qui permet justement
d'adapter en fonction des filières quand
il ya des difficultés
cet amendement
même si je partage le diagnostic
évidemment selon laquelle l'objectif de
développement du vrac n'appellera pas
une réponse uniforme pour tous les
produits réseaux de vente
nous souhaitons que la mesure prévue à
l'article en soit ambitieuse en
cohérence avec la proposition de la
convention citoyenne pour les climats
donc de ne pas exclure a priori certains
produits de grande consommation
dispositif d'autant plus que l'objectif
des 20%
il a été calibrée en tenant compte de la
surface de vente de ses produits en
calcul en tenant compte évidemment du
potentiel faible sur les produits
alcoolisés aujourd'hui potentiel faible
que tout le monde reconnaît et qui ne
pose évidemment pas de problème
particulier mais si on sort est produit
à cause du calcul la surface de vente
qu'ils représentent aujourd'hui il va
falloir augmenter
l'objectif de 20 % sinon on ne tiendra
pas donc pour autant évidemment on est
conscient des contraintes spécifiques le
gouvernement souhaite que l'article en
ménage une certaine souplesse dans la
mise en oeuvre de l'objectif en
prévoyant qu'il puisse se décliner en
fonction des spécificités des
différentes catégories de produits de
grande consommation donc j'émets un avis
défavorable
pas du tout pour qu'on fasse du vrac sur
tous les vins et spiritueux bien
évidemment mais pour que ce qu'on est en
train d'écrire puisse appliquer
correctement dans la réalité
je mets au veau à mes chers collègues je
mets ouvrez les trois amendements
identiques de 121 671 676 avec un avis
favorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés derniers amendements peut-être
ce avant la suspension le 2215
rédactionnelle de la commission madame
la ministre
favorable donc je le mets aux voix qui
et pour qui et contre fille s'abstient
il est adopté dans les discussions des
articles sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 2069 au sein de l'article 11 et
donc nous démarrons par l'amendement
donc 2069 madame avait bonjour madame la
présidente
il s'agit d'un amendement de
clarification permettant de préciser
qu'un producteur soumis au régime de
filiales à responsabilités élargies peut
être bénéficiaire nette des éco
contribution aux éco-organismes
lorsqu'il s'inscrit dans des pratiques
particulièrement vertueuse l'éco
contribution est la contrepartie
financière annuelle versée par une
entreprise un éco organisme agréé pour
la prise en charge de l'élimination des
déchets générés par ses activités en
vertu d'une filière de responsabilité
élargie des producteurs la filière
emballages est particulièrement concerné
par cet article actuellement la très
grande majorité des producteurs
contribuent à un des trois éco organisme
agréé ces éco organismes renverse
reverse pardon les contributions perçues
sous forme de soutien aux collectivités
pour le financement du dispositif de
collecte séparée du tri et du recyclage
des déchets d'emballages ménagers le tri
à la source des déchets d'emballages
ménagers est pratiqué par une très
grande majorité des français
cependant un effort fait cette affaire
sur la qualité du geste de tri pour
maîtriser les coûts de la filière et
faciliter le recyclage je vous remercie
merci l'avis de la commission même la
rapporteure adorable merci la fille du
gouvernement c'est un avis favorable
également bonsoir madame après
brown-forman le ministre merci donc je
mets au voile amendement 2069 qui a reçu
donc un avis favorable de la commission
et du gouvernement qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est donc adopté
quatre amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
le numéro 560 plein damas pour sow poli
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre dans sa rédaction issue de
l'assemblée
la loi prévoyait l'interdiction pure et
simple des polystyrène ps est pour lui
si rennes expansé cette posture brutale
ignoré la mise en place des filières de
recyclage en devenir notamment dans mon
département le pas de calais avec deux
entreprises qui est un vice qui
investissent qui vont créer des emplois
ils vont permettre non seulement de
trouver un débouché pour les
polystyrènes produit dans l'avenir mais
également de recycler ceux qui
s'entassent dans nos décharges où
doivent être brûlés faute de solution
les objectifs fixés par la loi anti
gaspillage de 100 % de produits
polymérique recyclables d'ici 2025 est
en bonne voie de se réaliser
et une fois encore j'ai eu l'occasion
constaté en visitant l'usiné ineos à
wingles en compagnie du maire et des
élus que nos entreprises ont de la
ressource
nous sommes en train de constituer un
écosystème industriel pertes mais
pertinent à l'échelle du département
allant de la production au recyclage en
passant par l'utilisation en effet au
delà de la seule question des pe ps eux
c'est aussi toute la filière
agroalimentaire qui s'interrogent les
emballages à base de polymères
styréniques sont indispensables pour la
conservation et la production de
nombreux produits notamment les produits
animaux tels que le poisson ou la viande
c'est aussi la filière du transport de
marchandises qui a explosé avec le
confinement qui est tributaire un
emballage de protection nos collègues de
la commission ont modifié le texte
initial pour exclure de l'interdiction
les polymères recyclables
s'il s'agit d'un progrès cela crée de
notre point de vue une ambiguïté sur ce
qui sera interdit ou pas et sur la
manière dont les contrôles
s'effectueront c'est pourquoi nous vous
demandons le retrait de ces alinéas
je vous remercie merci le 838 monsieur
cigolotti oui merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
dans le cadre de la loi avec le travail
du sénat avait déjà permis
l'introduction d'un objectif global de
transformation de la filière
industrielle des emballages plastique à
usage unique d'ici 2040 il est prévu la
mise en place effective d'une véritable
économie circulaire visant à considérer
chaque déchet comme une ressource afin
de limiter l'utilisation de matière
vierge
ainsi et nous apparaît important de
laisser encore une fois la loi hajek à
la loi geiq la possibilité de produire
ses effets et n'introduisons pas d
interdiction au gré des textes un cadre
juridique stable est indispensable pour
favoriser une économie circulaire
efficace cette interdiction introduite
dans le projet de loi sans étude
d'impact mettrait un coup d'arrêt à
l'ensemble des initiatives et on verrait
un signal particulièrement négatif à nos
industriels merci merci le 455 à
monsieur montard madame la présidente
cet amendement vise à rétablir le texte
de l'assemblée
il ne nous paraît pas du tout opportun
comme le propose la commission de créer
une exception à l'interdiction des
polymères ou de copolymères styréniques
plus connus seront des usages de
polystyrène
paris voit déjà de commencer par une
redéfinition de certains termes qui
jouent et qui me semble nécessaire
un embrayage un emballage pardon à usage
unique est un emballage qui n'est pas
conçu créer ou mis sur le marché pour
être rempli à nouveau ou réutilisés pour
un usage identique à sully pour lesquels
il a été conçu vous remarquerez que le
recyclage n'est pas évoquée dans cette
définition est à juste titre car lorsqu
un emballage en plastique à usage unique
et jetés après une seule utilisation
c'est
de la définition et un emballage à usage
unique
peu importe qu'ils soient recyclés par
la suite ou non je vous rappelle
également que la france est engagée à
mettre fin aux emballages platz et
plastique à usage unique d'ici 2040
nous avions aussi un amendement qui qui
demandait à ce que est ce que cette date
soit avancé à 2030 mais ce cet
amendement était jugée irrecevable
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans la
logique que cet objectif l'assemblée
propose d'interdire les emballages en
polystyrène en 2025
en effet le styrène qui est utilisé dans
la fabrication des polystyrènes et
hautement toxiques
celui ci est cancérigène se dégrade en
nanoparticules dans l'environnement et
met plus de mille ans à disparaître il
est également nocif pour les organismes
aquatiques ce qui n'est pas négligeable
car le polystyrène représente par
exemple 3 2% des milliers de tonnes de
débris flottant en mer méditerranée
par ailleurs aucune solution de
recyclage certaines n'existe à ce stade
en effet ces plastiques styréniques
nuisent au recyclage et représente
actuellement 40 2% des plastiques
incinérés ce n'est pas rendre service
aux industriels que de créer cette
exception pour des polystyrènes
potentiellement recyclables et de
pousser les industriels dans les dents
des investissements de recherche et
développement unités et nuit inutile
étant donné que ces emballages et je les
ai rappelés seront de toute façon
interdite en 2040 au plus tard la loi
dont on doit envoyer un signal clair aux
acteurs économiques
nous avons donc un nous invite vous
invitons donc à supprimer cette
exception merci le 1766 n'est pas
défendu donc
la parole est à la commission même les
rapporteurs merci madame la présidente
la commission a considéré que la
suppression de la disposition être
introduite par l'assemblée nationale
concernant les emballages polystyrène
n'était pas opportune
il nous a semblé plus sécurisant de
trouver une solution équilibrée
c'est le sens de l'amendement que nous
avons adoptée en commission qui vise à
restreindre l'interdiction au seul
emballage en polystyrène non recyclables
et dans l'incapacité d'intégrer une
filière recyclage à compter du 1er
janvier 2000 25
l'amendement que nous avons adoptée en
commission laisse ainsi la possibilité
aux acteurs du secteur
d'opérationnaliser de généraliser avant
cette date les solutions de recyclage
promise je ne souhaite pas revenir sur
cet équilibre trouvé et qui était en
fait l' équilibre trouvé à l'occasion de
l'adoption de la loi à gec donc j'ai
aimé un avis défavorable aux amendements
de suppression 560 et 838 avis également
défavorable à l'amendement 455 qui lui
souhaitent revenir à la rédaction de
l'assemblée nationale avis défavorable
enfin au 1766 mais je crois qu'il n'est
pas défendu donc bon à 8 défavorable de
toute façon merci la vie du gouvernement
madame la ministre
merci madame
la présidente l'utilisation du
polystyrène dans les emballages n'est
pas récente
et pourtant près de 30 ans après la
création de la filière rep sur les
emballages ménagers
ces emballages reste à ce jour très
faiblement recyclé seulement trois à
quatre mille tonnes sur environ 100
mille tonnes d'emballages ménagers en
polystyrène produites par an sont
recyclés hors de france pour fabriquer
des produits comme des cintres ou des
pots de fleurs les plastiques
styréniques représente ainsi 42% des
plastiques incinérés et 27 % de ceux qui
sont enfouis alors qu'il ne pèse qu'une
quinzaine de pourcents du marché de
l'emballage
il contribue donc à ce que nous
n'atteignons pas nos objectifs européens
de recyclage et grèvent notre bilan
carbone
alors où nous avons voté la sortie du
plastique à usage unique dans la loi
anti gaspillage d'ici 2040 et où nous
avons fixé objectif de tendre vers 100 %
de plastique recyclés d'ici le 1er
janvier 2000 25 il est indispensable que
les résines employés soient recyclables
et dispose d'une filière de recyclage
opérationnel dans le cadre du pacte
national emballages plastiques qui
réunit des producteurs des distributeurs
des ong et le ministère de la transition
écologique autour d'engagements
volontaires certaines marques et
distributeurs de produits frais se sont
d'ailleurs saisi de ce sujet et ont
appelé à une décision rapide des
signataires concernés par le polystyrène
pour choisir de mettre fin à leur
utilisation du polystyrène dans les
emballages l'assemblée nationale s'est
également saisie de ce sujet en votant
madame la rapporteure la dig
interdiction des emballages en
polystyrène en 2025 et le travail en
commission du sénat a cherché à rendre
plus opérationnels la mesurant la cible
en sur des emballages non recyclables
dans l'est dans la capacité d'intégrer
une filière de recyclage
dans ce contexte les acteurs de la
filière industrielle du polystyrène ont
transmis hier une charte d'engagement
pour réduire l'impact de leurs
emballages sur l'environnement dans
laquelle ils s'engagent à développer une
nouvelle filière de recyclage capable de
produire une matière recyclée avec
retour au contact alimentaire permettant
le recyclage effectif de 100 % des
emballages en polystyrène collecté tri
en france en 2025
le développement de cette filière
s'appuiera sur des pilotes puis des
usines
industrielle dès 2023 porté par michelin
ineos et total la filière s'engage aussi
dans cette charte à examiner
périodiquement et ce dès fin 2021
l'existence ou non de perspectives avec
le comité des parties prenantes de la
charte afin de s'orienter le cas échéant
vers un plan de sortie du polystyrène
vers d'autres solutions possédant une
filière de réemploi ou de recyclage
efficiente je souhaite également
rappeler que pour le ppt qui est une des
alternatives au polystyrène
il sera également nécessaire de
développer la filière de recyclage péter
pour les peaux et barquettes et que
j'appelle de mes voeux le développement
d'initiatives collectives similaire à
celle de la charte pour le polystyrène
la disposition votée en commission au
sénat me semble offrir un cadre
approprié à cet engagement des acteurs
de la filière polystyrène et en
complément de cette disposition
j'utiliserai le vis réglementaire
relatif à la filière rep emballages pour
définir plus précisément la notion
d'emballages recyclables afin que pour
ainsi que pour fixer des objectifs
d'incorporation deux mètres de matières
recyclées la filière rep emballages
accompagnera aussi ses engagements grâce
au système de primes et de pénalités qui
a été renforcée dans le cadre de la loi
anti gaspillage
ainsi la loi anti gaspillage prévoit
qu'un arrêté fixe pour 2022
une pénalité applicables aux emballages
plastiques ne peuvent intégrer une
filière de recyclage
le polystyrène est par ailleurs comme
d'autres régimes concernés par le
dispositif de bonus à l'incorporation de
plastique recyclé dans des emballages
qui a été mis en place
en 2021 c'est pourquoi il ne me semble
ni pertinent de revenir à la disposition
de ces dispositions votées à l'assemblée
nationale ni de les supprimer car ses
dispositions témoigne du travail
parlementaire menée sur le sujet vont
dans le sens des engagements des acteurs
dans leur transition
je ne serai pas toujours aussi longue
mesdames et messieurs et sénatrices et
sénateurs
mais je tenais à faire ses remarques
pour ajouter que je suis donc
défavorable aux amendements présentés et
madame un pourceau poli
l'entreprise ineos à wingles je le dis
et une entreprise d'avenir parce que
c'est une entreprise qui effectivement
créé aujourd'hui et se sert du polymère
parce que pour rappel quand même les
éléments dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure le poisson la viande la glace
les fruits et légumes sur les grandes
distances sans briser la chaîne du froid
ce qui est qu'ils ne sont qui sont
sujets à des contaminations extérieures
est sensible à la chaleur
aujourd'hui ces produits ne peuvent pas
être vendus en vrac et l'entreprise
ineos ce qu'elle se propose de faire
c'est justement de créer donc des
emplois parce qu'on parle aussi
d'emplois et de créer une chaîne de
production pour justement aller à une
chaîne de production spéciale recyclage
pour pouvoir donc recyclé sebag de
polystyrène
voilà si de toute façon nous ne le
faisons pas et bien d'autres pays le
ferons on parle ici d'une set d'une
chaîne de recyclage pour le polystyrène
mais si monsieur le président gaudin oui
merci madame la présidente c'était pour
aller dans le sens de de ce qu'a dit
angèle angem préville je pense que
soient dangereuses dangerosité du
produit et polystyrène jr qui est plus à
plus à démontrer mais surtout c'est sur
le message qui du coup est donnée parce
que ça veut dire qu'on dit encore une
fois aux industriels continuer dans
cette recherche continuer à utiliser ce
produit alors qu'il me semble que la
disposition qui avait dans le texte de
l'assemblée nationale qui d'ailleurs
était je crois une disposition qui avait
été intégré par par la majorité
présidentielle
je comprends pas pourquoi on revient on
revient en arrière je rappelle et je les
ai dit tout à l'heure
l'usl
les plastiques et les plastiques à usage
unique on en sait dans la loi geiq
seront interdits à partir de 2040 et la
totalité de plastique à usage unique
donc on a plutôt intérêt à donner ce
signal la aux industriels est plutôt à
changer et à arrêter le développement de
ceux de ce polystyrène et donc je
comprends absolument pas ce retour en
arrière
merci donc je vais mettre aux voix les
deux amendements identiques 560 et 838
qui ont reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient n'ont
pas adopté l'amendement 455 donc et reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission et
du gouvernement qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adoptée jeu mais se voit l'article 11
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté à l'article 11 bis
la maman 2216 présenté par même le
rapporteur président même liste avis
favorable donc je mets aux voix la maman
2216 qui est donc un avis favorable du
gouvernement est présenté par la
commission tpour qui est contraint qui
s'abstient il est donc adopté trois
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune de 736 présenté par
madame préville merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre michelle
collègues 80% des 1800 élus locaux ayant
répondu à la consultation lancée par le
sénat sur le projet de loi climat et
résilience constate une augmentation des
déchets issus de la vente à emporter et
de la restauration livrée 85 % des
répondants estimé nécessaire de mieux
lutter contre ces déchets le présent
amendement vise à répondre à cette
préoccupation en prévoyant qu'à compter
du 1er janvier
25 les services de restauration
collective soient tenus de proposer au
consommateur d'être servis dans un
contenant réutilisable ou composées de
matières recyclables dès lors qu'ils
proposent des services de vente à
emporter pour la suppression de la
mention bio sourcés je tiens à rappeler
qu'un plastique qu'une matières
plastiques biosourcés ou d'origine
fossile
c'est là exactement la même matière et
qu'elle présente les mêmes inconvénients
et quelque part les mêmes avantages
voilà donc j'ai estimé que cela rendait
encore peut-être plus difficile
l'application de cet article
si on maintenait le bio sourcés puisque
ça n'a pas voilà on n'y voit pas de
change pas traire il n'y a pas de
progrès a forcément être sur le bio sur
c'est surtout qu'on peut se poser la
question d'où vient le bio sourcés merci
deux amendements identiques le 393 me
cigolotti merci madame la présidente
l'article 11 prévoit qu'à compter du 1er
janvier 2000 25 et services de
restauration collective proposant des
services de vente à emporter sont tenus
de proposer au consommateur d'être
servis dans un contenant réutilisable ou
compostés de manière biosourcés et
recyclables
même si une utilisation raisonnée des
emballages en plastique à usage unique
reste un objectif pour le respect de
l'environnement
il est important de soutenir l'ensemble
des solutions innovantes sur lesquels
les industriels de l'emballage travaille
depuis déjà quelques années
cet amendement vise donc aux côtés des
solutions de réemploi ou d'emballages
biosourcés à inclure les emballages
recyclables s'inscrivant ainsi dans les
filières de recyclage opérationnelles
afin de poursuivre dans la continue
encore la continuité de la loi geiq
l'objectif d'atteindre le 100 % de
plastique recyclé à l'horizon 2025 merci
merci l'amendement 563 monsieur fabre au
madame la présidente
chers collègues je reviens sur le sujet
qui vient d'être révoqué donc les
emballages ménagers et sur un produit
que vous connaissez tous très bien pour
avoir
au cours des mois passés déguster les
mets que vous servez le restaurant du
sénat puisque ce sont donc des
contenants alimentaires papier-carton
généralement et qui sont à même
d'accueillir les road forte et donc il
s'agit là d'un amendement qui est a déjà
été visé par la commission et j'ai
déposé sur la jusque-là l'amendement
adopté par la commission un amendement
correctifs
car je pense que les exigences du
premier amendement me paraissait
excessive
en effet le premier amendement précisé
que les contenants réutilisables est
composé de matières bio sourcées ou
recyclables excusez moi j'ai un petit
problème de classement
l'amendement visait des contenants
réutilisables composé matières bio
sourcées ou recyclables et ses
amendements
cet amendement je suis vraiment j'ai
bien fait de le mettre par écrit
d'ailleurs si le papier le carton qui
composent donc que les contenants
alimentaires dont je parle sont toujours
recyclables et bio sourcés seuls
certains plastiques utilisés pour les
contenants alimentaires sont recyclables
mais très peu de ces contenants sont bio
sourcés ce qui me fait dire que
l'exigence du cumul du recyclable et du
bio sourcés est une exigence qui libre
est justifié et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je demande que l'amendement
soit modifiée sur un point seulement
c'est à dire que cet amendement précise
que les les contenants alimentaires qui
sont concernés doivent être composées de
matériaux biosourcés ou recyclables et
non bio sourcés airs site la voilà avec
quelques excuses pour ses hésitations
qui ont affecté ma présentation
merci l'avis de la commission pour
l'amendement 730 6 oui il me semble
madame préville de prévoir que
il me semble qu'il est nécessaire de
prévoir que les contenants soit composé
à la fois de matières bio sourcés et
recyclable et en effet pour cette raison
là on va donner un avis enfin je donne
un avis défavorable à votre amendement
sur les deux identiques le 393 et le 563
rectifier il est indispensable en fait
je souhaiterais le rappeler que les
contenants soit composé de matières bio
sourcés est heureux et est recyclable en
effet et non pas bio sourcées ou
recyclables
car sinon nous prenons le risque que
nous ayons une augmentation des refus en
fait dans les centres de tri qui sont
gérés par nos collectivités
territoriales la voilà la raison pour
laquelle je donne un avis défavorable
aux deux amendements
merci même les rapporteurs même les
ministres l'avis du gouvernement oui
merci à la présidente alors moi je
j'émets un avis favorable à l'amendement
736 présenté par madame préville parce
qu'effectivement la disposition tels que
prévu actuellement ne permet pas
l'utilisation de matières non bio
sourcés qui pourtant peuvent pour
certaines être parfaitement recyclables
notamment en boucle fermée et al'inverse
certaines matières bio sourcés
recyclables peuvent avoir un impact
environnemental négatif notamment
lorsqu'elles viennent perturber le
recyclage d'autres matériaux s ou
lorsqu'elles se retrouvent dans
l'environnement et enfin votre
amendement mais en cohérence cet article
11 bis avec les dispositions que nous
avons récemment adoptée au parlement
dans le cadre de la loi anti gaspillage
ce qui me paraît nécessaire pour que
tous les établissements proposant des
repas à emporter et les mêmes règles à
respecter
donc cet amendement apparaît très bon et
et j'insiste sur le risque sur les
matières bio sourcés donc avis favorable
pour cet amendement et pour les deux
suivants c'est un avis défavorable
en tout cas une demande de retrait au
profit de l'amendement de madame
préville je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement 736 ya reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission est
favorable du gouvernement
ah vous voulez oui bien sûr c'est juste
que je ne vous ai pas vu leur apportant
tout à fait ce que ce que vous dites
chers collègues mais en fait aujourd'hui
on voit bien que nous avons une
augmentation c'est un rapport qui a été
fait ici chez nous et qui nous montre
justement que lorsque nous avons affaire
à des produits qui sont bio sourcés et
recyclables il n'y a pas de souci de tri
dans nos centres de gestion en revanche
lorsqu'ils sont l'un ou l'autre ça peut
créer parfois des refus donc c'était le
sens en réalité de cette réécriture que
nous avons adoptées au niveau de la
commission
je voulais apporter cette précision pour
pas qu'il y ait d'ambiguïté
mais merci donc je mets au voile
amendement 736 qui a reçu donc un avis
défavorable de la commission est
favorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté les deux amendements identiques
donc 393 et 563 qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour c'est contre
ça tient et ne sont pas adoptées à
l'article 12 je donne la parole à
monsieur daniel laurent oui madame la
présidente madame la ministre van hamme
le rapporteur cet article est important
puisqu'il concerne en partie la consigne
la rédaction proposée par le premier
alinéa de l'article 12 préoccupe
l'ensemble de la filière des boissons
alcoolisées madame là à porter vous
proposer dans votre amendement
2222 de décaler l'adoption du dispositif
de consignes pour ré emploi pour les
emballages en verre après la publication
de l'évaluation conduite par
l'observatoire dur emploi et de la
réutilisation
j'avoue est très perplexe les
producteurs de vin de spiritueux ou de
bière ont le sentiment que le fait de
décaler la définition d'une trajectoire
vers la cible est un risque que votre
proposition ne prend pas en compte les
enjeux de traçabilité ni de la sécurité
des consommateurs
la rédaction proposée conduit à une
consigne obligatoire qui va à l'encontre
d'une filière solide fleuron de nos
exportations et de l'attractivité de nos
territoires nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir pendant la présentation de nos
amendements mais ne convient-il pas de
laisser les producteurs s'organisent et
en laissant recourir à la consigne pour
ré emploi
selon channel fille science d'un point
de vue économique et environnemental
madame la ministre madame la reporter
essayer d'entendre les inquiétudes de la
filière et comment pouvons-nous imaginer
qu ont signé une nouvelle fois les
bouteilles de champagne d'armagnac de
cognac ou de 20 ça me semble
complètement insensé merci l'amendement
60,18 monsieur démunis en france la
consigne a longtemps été la norme puis à
partir des années 60 70 industries agro
alimentaires commencent à privilégier
les contenants jetables
ces nouveaux emballages étant présentés
par les groupes industriels comme plus
moderne plus pratique et surtout plus
léger après avoir pratiquement disparu
la pratique de la consigne rené avec
l'essor de l'économie circulaire depuis
quelques années à l'échelle locale
notamment
il existe une réelle prise de conscience
de la nécessité de modifier nos
habitudes et nos modes de consommation
j'avais d'ailleurs
déposer une proposition parlementaire de
loin en 2006 à l'assemblée nationale sur
le sujet nous devons réduire nos déchets
nous devons ré utiliser tout ce qui peut
l'être
nous devons recyclé autant que possible
et une bouteille en verre peut être
réutilisé jusqu'à 50 fois
selon l'ademe la con s'il permettrait
d'économiser d'économiser jusqu'à 80 %
d'énergie la rédaction initiale de
l'article 12 impliquer la nécessaire
généralisation de la consigne afin
d'atteindre nos objectifs nationaux et
européens en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
ainsi qu'un bilan environnement
environnementale pardon global positif
mais la réécriture de l'article 12 lors
des travaux de l'assemblée nationale l'a
rendu inopérant puisque a été supprimé
la généralisation de la consigne d
emballage de verre pour lui substituer
des décisions au cas par cas
cet amendement vise donc à rétablir son
article dans sa version initiale issue
du conseil des ministres puisqu'il me
reste quelques poignées de secondes
permettez moi de conclure sur une
boutade
on veut créer un observatoire du
réemploi de la réutilisation
je m'interroge de façon globale sur le
nombre d'observatoire commissions et
instances consultatives en france on
devient vraiment les champions du monde
en la matière en 2020 on en comptait 381
7 pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique ont trait parfois
paradoxalement des usines à gaz
on finira à madame la présidente par
créer un observatoire des observatoires
même les rapporteurs l'avis de la
commission
alors chers collègues je ne serais pas
étonné que je donne un avis défavorable
puisque le retour à la rédaction de
l'assemblée nationale proposée dans cet
amendement n'est pas au portant la
rédaction de l'assemblée national
n'apportait rien en droit puisque la loi
geiq a déjà permis de mettre en place
des dispositifs de consignes pour l
emploi par ailleurs cet amendement
revient supprimer les éléments justement
relatifs à l'observatoire du réemploi et
de la rue réutilisation que juste pour
lesquelles nous avons beaucoup débattu à
l'occasion de l'examen de la loi à gex
ce que donc je ne juge pas souhaitable
donc la vie effectivement défavorable
merci même ministre et du gouvernement
merci madame la présidente alors je
crois que
l'amendement ne vise pas à rétablir la
rédaction de l'assemblée nationale mais
la rédaction initiale de l'article 12
il me semble c'est bien ça et donc en
fait moi je n'y suis pas favorable alors
que nous sommes évidemment le
gouvernement a déposé cet article 12 mai
nous considérons que les débats qui ont
eu lieu à l'assemblée nationale puis en
commission au sénat
me semble utile et la rédaction à
laquelle ce travail a permis d'aboutir
ne renonce pas à l'ambition initiale et
renforce les garanties autour de
l'évaluation de la mise en place d'une
consigne d1 belge d'anvers et notamment
en s'appuyant sur les travaux de
l'observateur du réemploi et de la
réutilisation donc je pense que les
travaux ont été utiles et je trouve
dommage de de les supprimer et
d'ailleurs dans les travaux issus de
l'assemblée nationale et de la
commission il y à toutes les mesures
pour rassurer la filière des vins et
spiritueux puisque justement des
précautions sont mises pour éviter des
absurdités et je crois que tout le monde
sera bien d'accord pour dire que on ne
va pas mettre en place une consigne
quand ça n'a strictement aucun sens d'un
point de vue ni économique ni
environnementale
ce qui serait le cas si par exemple on
faisait jeudi d' avance la réponse aux
objections que j'ai déjà entendu il est
évident que quand on fait par exemple
beaucoup d'exportation le bilan
environnemental pour aller rechercher à
l'étranger une bouteille de vin ou une
bouteille de spiritueux est mauvais sans
avoir ces senteurs d'études sur le sujet
on peut le dire tout de suite donc là
c'est une évidence qu'on ne fera pas la
consigne dans ces cas-là et
des mesures sont prises et sont
préconisées grâce aux travaux qui ont eu
lieu dans c dans les deux assemblées
pour justement éviter ce genre
d'absurdité dans laquelle personne ne
veut tomber
merci alors je mets au voile amendement
78 kg a reçu un avis favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient pas
adopté 18 amendement faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 226 même la
présidente de la train merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
dans son rapport remis en mars dernier
l'ademe qui est une agence reconnue pour
son expertise
madame la ministre et président est
d'ailleurs par un gironde a estimé qu'il
était possible d'atteindre l'objectif de
90 % de collecte de bouteilles en verre
en 2029 sans recourir à la consigne la
dame a pointé des pistes d'amélioration
comme le renforcement de la tarification
incitative la densification de points
d'apport de proximité ou encore la mise
en place d'un dispositif de contrôle des
gestes de tri
la solution repose sur la combinaison de
ces différents leviers d'amélioration
qu'elle peut s'ajouter un dispositif de
consignes qui doit être volontaire
en effet les bénéfices environnementaux
d'une généralisation nationale d'un
dispositif de consignes pour ré emploi
ne vont pas de soi
comme le souligne le rapport de l'ademe
qui estime qu'au delà de 260 kilomètres
alors madame la ministre comme vous ne
parliez de l'export 260 kilomètres on
est encore en france donc au delà du
bénéfice au delà de 160 km le bilan
environnemental est négatif or la france
ne compte pas ou peu de bassins de
consommation exclusivement régionaux les
transports des bouteilles en verre vide
à travers l'ensemble du territoire
pourrait donc avoir un lourd impact
environnemental des initiatives en
matière de consignes est au niveau local
sur la base du volontariat
y compris au sein de la filière viticole
très volontaire en la matière je puis
vous l'assurer
lorsque ce dispositif est adapté au
regard de la demande et qu'ils aiment
clic et qu'ils n'impliquent pas de
transport de bouteilles vides sur des
longues distances
laissons aux producteurs la possibilité
de s'adapter au contexte local sans leur
imposer une obligation contre-productive
du point de vue environnemental
or ces retards critique amendé en
commission ici au sénat en proposant la
mise en place d'une trajectoire
d'évolution de la proportion minimale
d'emballages en verre est employé à
mettre sur le marché annuellement en
france
rentré ce dispositif trop contraignant
mettant plus la malle la filière ce qui
n'est pas le moment mes chers collègues
madame la rapporteure ne soyez pas
jusqu'au-boutistes le toujours plus peut
être néfaste
le présent amendement vise donc à
revenir à l'équilibré adopté par
l'assemblée nationale en supprimant
cette trajectoire et en précisant
l'aspect volontaire du dispositif de
consignes pour et emploi lorsque le
bilan environnemental économique et
social global est positif
comme il est aujourd'hui je vous le
rappelle merci quatre amendements
identiques le 66 monsieur laurent oui il
présente amendement madame la présidente
vise à supprimer la définition par
décret d'une trajectoire d'évolution de
la proportion minimale d'emballages en
verre est employé à mettre sur le marché
annuellement en france le réemploi du
verre est principalement effectués via
les dispositifs de consignes de vrac
il a été reconnu que pour les bouteilles
en verre destiné à contenir des boissons
alcoolisées soit près de 90 % les
possibilités de vente en vrac sont
limitées et risque donc de rendre le
dispositif inopérant la mise en place du
dispositif de consignes pour et emploi
doit être envisagée à l'aune de sa
pertinence environnementale et pour
compléter ce que je disait madame la
ministre tout à l'heure simplement lui
dire que bien sûr que
comprends que vous n'avez pas envie de
consignes et peut-être les bouteilles de
nos prénoms de nos bons produits que
nous avons en france mais vous me
l'écrire que le dire merci à eux le 123
monsieur chassaing madame la présidente
chers collègues donc j'ai même
amendement qui prévoit qui vise à
supprimer la définition par décret d'une
trajectoire d'évolution de la proportion
minimale d'emballages en verre les
employés à mettre sur le marché
annuellement en france un dispositif
similaire est déjà prévue par la loi
l'article 67 de la loi relative à la
lutte contre le gaspillage et l'économie
circulaire prêt ou high tech à la
définition par décret d'une trajectoire
d'évolution de la proportion minimale
d'emballage réemployer à mettre sur le
marché sans distinction de matériel
merci merci le 224 même la présidente
nathalie delattre
oui merci madame la présidente madame
ministre mes chers collègues la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable a
intégré au sein de l'article 12 la
définition par décret d'une trajectoire
d'évolution de la proportion minimale
d'emballages en verre réemployer à
mettre sur le marché annuellement en
france
ce faisant la généralisation de la
consigne pour y emploie a désormais
valeur contraignante
comme je l'expliquais précédemment la
consigne pour les emplois est un
dispositif inadapté aux besoins du
secteur de la vigne et du vin
l'impact environnemental d'une telle
mesure généralisée à l'échelle nationale
est très incertain et potentiellement
délétères
il est indispensable de conserver le
caractère volontaire de cette dispositif
de ce dispositif pour tenir compte des
situations et des contextes au cas par
cas et laisser les initiatives émerger
par ailleurs l'article 67 de la loi
relative à la lutte contre le gaspillage
l'économie circulaire prévoit déjà la
définition d'une telle trajectoire sans
distinction de matériaux ce qui me
paraît préférable
sachant que la pertinence
environnemental économique de la
consigne pour ré emploi pour les
emballages en verre
doit faire l'objet d'une évaluation
avant le 1er janvier 2023
c'est donc demain le présente amendement
vise donc à supprimer la mise en place
d'une trajectoire d'évolution de la
proportion minimale d'emballages en
verre réemployer à mettre sur le marché
annuellement ce qui ne veut pas dire que
la filière ne fait pas d'effort bien de
bien au contraire et je voudrais la
saluer à cette occasion merci merci
l'amendement 1952 monsieur montaugé
merci madame la présidente madame le
ministre chers collègues je vais éviter
de paraphraser les arguments qui ont été
développés puisque l'amendement mais
honda mène de main mais est commun aux
trois précédents je voudrais juste
rajouter qui nous paraît 2
de l'eau géologique
d'atteindre les résultats de
l'évaluation mais qui doivent être
faites donc avant le 1er janvier 2000 e
23 22 statuer sur le réemploi de
contenants en verre
donc nous pensons qu'il est nécessaire
de supprimer purement et simplement
cette ce premier alinéa de l'article de
l'article 12
et je rajouterais s'il fallait trouver
un argument mais un peu original que
mais ça a déjà été un peu dit aussi que
le que le vert pour pour le vin par ses
spécificités se prête mal et avec des
risques pour les utilisateurs pour les
consommateurs eux mêmes auraient emplois
directs voilà et jeu je tiens aussi à
souligner les efforts que fait la
filière pour malgré tout recycler le
vérin quand cela est nécessaire et ils y
arrivent dans des proportions quand même
significative et je tiens moi aussi
alors à le souligner 500 2 599 n'est pas
défendu de 771 du président gontard
merci madame la présidente je l' ai
rappelé tout à l'heure la france s'est
dotée avec la logique d'un d'un objectif
d'abandon des emballages plastique à
usage unique ans en 2040
le groupe écologie souhaitait avancer
cet objectif à 2030 et cet amendement
avait été jugée recevable en commission
mais a été jugé irrecevable en séance au
titre de l'article 45 en tant que
cavalier dans un texte qui vise pourtant
favorisé la vente sans emballage les
emballages réemployables on ne peut donc
pas interdire certains temps certains
types d'emballages à usage unique
comprenne qui pourra le raisonnement
juridique subtil qui amène à considérer
l'absence de lien direct avec le texte
mais je reviens sur sur l'amendement
pour tenir l'objectif de 2040 et a
fortiori l'objectif écologistes de 2030
il est indispensable de déployer la
vente sans emballage et les emballages
réemployables c'est l'objet du présent
amendement qui vise à muscler dans
l'article liminaire du type déchets du
code de l'environnement les objectifs de
mise sur le marché dans blaye âge
réemployables nous proposons donc deux
échelons 20 % en 2025 et 50 % en 2030
sommes lucides sur la hauteur des
marches à gravir
nous avons comme vous l'aurez souligné
repousser l'échéance à un horizon
ambitieux et donc atteignable ces
objectifs s'inscrivent naturellement
dans le mécanisme de la responsabilité
élargie du producteur
il a également pour effet d' harmoniser
les objectifs de réemploi pour
l'ensemble des matériaux de la filière
rep des emballages ménagers qui souffre
aujourd'hui de nombreuses disparités
ils ont également vocation à être
transcrit sous forme d'objectifs de
résultats dans les cahiers des charges
des filières rep des emballages ménagers
et professionnels
merci merci l'amendement 300 monsieur
guillaume oui c'est ça merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mais
chaque collègue l'article l541 du code
de l'environnement fixe les objectifs en
matière de réemploi des emballages
ménagers soit une proportion de 5 % 2023
et de 10% 2027
le manque d'uniformité des objectifs qui
diffère en fonction des matériaux
concernés et l'absence de contrainte
freine les progrès en la matière le
présente amendement vise donc à
harmoniser les objectifs de réemploi
pour l'ensemble des matériaux de la
filière en responsabilité élargie des
producteurs des emballages ménagers et à
les intégrer au sein des cahiers des
charges des filières des rep des
emballages ménagers et professionnels
afin de les rendre plus contraignante et
donc d'assurer leur effectivité
si le 672 n'est pas défendu l'amendement
2222 même de sidrac pour la commission
oui madame la présidence et un
amendement qui vise à préciser que le
décret fixant la trajectoire d'évolution
de la proportion minimale d'emballages
en verre est employé à mettre sur le
marché devra être pris après la
publication de l'évaluation du
dispositif de consignes pour ré emploi
par l'observatoire du réemploi et de la
réutilisation devant être effectués au
plus tard au 1er janvier 2023
je ne
merci quatre amendements identiques le
67 monsieur laurent c'est un amendement
de repli puisque le présent amendement
vise à exclure les boissons alcooliques
de la définition par décret d'une
trajectoire d'évolution de la proportion
minimale d'emballages en verre est
employé à mettre sur le marché
finalement en france le réemploi du
verre et principe en principalement
effectués via les dispositifs de
consignes de vrac
il a été reconnu que pour les bouteilles
en verre destiné à contenir des boissons
alcoolisées soit près de 90 % les
possibilités de vente en vrac sont
limitées et risque donc de rendre le
disposer de dispositifs inopérant merci
l'amendement 124 monsieur chassaing le
présent amendement dont kobe tu es plus
dans les boissons alcooliques de la
définition par décret d'une trajectoire
d'évolution de la proportion minimale
d'emballages en verre est employé à
mettre sur le marché actuellement en
france un 10 pouces difficile il est
déjà prévu par la loi je répète
l'article 67 de la loi relative à la
lutte contre le gaspillage économie
circulaire prévoit déjà la définition
par décret d'une trajectoire d'évolution
de la proportion minimale d'emballage
réemployer à mettre sur marché sans
distinction de matériaux merci merci la
maman 953 monsieur montaugé
merci madame la présidente
donc cet amendement est un amendement de
repli il vise à exclure les boissons
alcooliques de la définition par décret
d'une trajectoire d'évolution de la
proportion minimale d'emballage enverra
employé à mettre sur le marché
annuellement en france donc un
dispositif similaire comme l'indiquait
déjà prévues par la loi
l'article 67 de la loi relative à la
lutte contre le gaspillage et à
l'économie circulaire prévoit déjà donc
la définition par décret d'une
trajectoire d'évolution de la proportion
minimale d'emballage réemployer à mettre
sur le marché comme ça a été soulignée
le réemploi du verre s'effectue
principalement via les dispositifs de
consigne en vrac donc le présente
arctique tel qu issu des travaux de la
commission dispose justement qu'une
évaluation d'un dispositif de consignes
pour des emplois pour les emballages en
verre est effectuée avant le 1er janvier
2023 par l'observatoire du réemploi de
la réutilisation donc prévue à l'article
la doc et qui atteste sa pertinence
environnemental et économique
cela souligne bien l'intérêt du
dispositif que l'intérêt du dispositif
n'est pas encore assurée d'autant plus
que l'ademe doit mener des travaux
complémentaires plus encore plus de 90 %
des emballages en verre sont destinés à
contenir des boissons alcoolisées pour
lesquelles leur emploi déjà possible
sous forme volontaire n'offrent que des
avantages très limité compte tenu des
enjeux de préservation de la qualité et
de distance entre les lieux de
production et ceux de consommation au vu
de ce qui précède il apparaît donc
incohérent de définir une trajectoire
pour les emballages de boissons
alcoolisées en l'absence d'une analyse
préalable de la pertinence des
dispositifs qui permettraient de la
déployer si l'amendement 1785 à monsieur
klinger oui merci - le présidente c'est
un amendement qui est identique à celui
de mon collègue dernier laurent alors je
vais pas répéter les mêmes arguments de
tout le monde simplement
vous exposez une expérience personnelle
j'étais il ya quelques années encore
directeur d'une cave coopérative
viticole et nous avons il ya une
vingtaine d'années on a tous arrêter les
emballages consigné tout simplement
parce qu'il y avait des coûts de
manutention qu'il y avait aussi qu'on
s'est rendu compte qu'on transportait à
travers toute la france des bouteilles
vides je n'ai pas certain que le bilan
carbone ne soit positif avec toutes ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre est
tout simplement parce que le coup était
plus cher
on va donc par ce dispositif si vous le
maintenez augmenter les coûts de
production de nos entreprises d'une
filière viticole qui est qui qui a du
mal à s'en sortir ils ont connu la taxe
trump ils ont connu la période de la cog
vide on rajoute le coup de gel qui s'est
encore rajouté en début d'année donc je
pense que on pourrait un peu attendre
sur ce système de verres consignés clip
franchement n'a pas beaucoup davantage
gardons le système les apports de poing
volontaire de conexpo de guerre cela
fonctionne très bien
donc ne ne rajoutons pas des charges à
nos entreprises françaises qui ont des
difficultés parce que nos collègues
européens ne peut ne le font pas merci
d'amendements 1366 écoles mais ça merci
madame la présidente le présent
amendement propose de renommer
l'observatoire du réemploi et de la
réutilisation dont les missions sont
précisés à l'article 12 du projet de loi
en y ajoutant dans le mot réparation en
effet l'article 62 de la loi du 10
février 2000 relative à la lutte contre
le gaspillage à l'économie circulaire
prévoit la mise en place d'un fonds
dédié au financement de la réparation
abondé par les éco contribution des
producteurs soumis à la rép
à compter de 2022 dès lors est pas
cohérent sur l'observatoire peut-être
pourrait être chargée du suivi des
informations et des études liées à la
réparation encore de l'impact du fonds
de réparation sur le nombre de
réparations
effectivement réalisées sur les coûts de
cette préparation reste à la charge du
consommateur ou des pièces détachées tel
est l'objet de cet amendement merci
l'amendement 225 quand même la
présidente nathalie delattre
mais je vais juste vous demander de
faire un tout petit peu moins de bruit
merci merci chars présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues c'est un
amendement de repli
je voudrais juste redire que le
recyclage de verre n'est pas jugée
problématique par l'ademe
au contraire elle note l'exemplarité du
recyclage de ce matériau vous dire aussi
qu'il est le seul continent qui assure
aujourd'hui le vieillissement du vin et
le vieillissement optimum de ce produit
qui nous est cher et patrimoniale
imposer cela à nos viticulteurs français
qui font déjà beaucoup d'efforts c'est
encore leur envoyer un signe négatif
la coupe est pleine il n'ya pas d'autre
alternative alors chers collègues
soyons responsables ce qui est
normalement la marque de fabrique du
sénat et nous nous trompons pas de
combat donc merci de soutenir ces
amendements merci l'amendement 1767
n'est pas défendu l'amendement 1098 même
joseph madame la présidente le présent
amendement donc vise à modifier
l'alinéa 6 de cet article 12 modifie la
rédaction proposé d'insérer les mots en
concertation avec les professions
concernées afin de connaître au mieux
les contraintes et les réalités des
professionnels des professions
concernées par cet article la
concertation de ces derniers ne
pourraient qu'être bénéfique à l'analyse
conduite par l'observatoire du réemploi
et de la réutilisation
il importe de tenir compte de l'ensemble
des enjeux pour élaborer au mieux une
politique nationale qui posera les
jalons vers un bilan environnemental
global positif
merci alors l'avis de la commission pour
l'ensemble de ces amendements même la
rapporteure oui merci madame la
présidente
évidemment mes commentaires seront un
petit peu long compte tenu du nombre
d'amendements qui ont été déposés tous
allant plus ou moins
dans le même sens donc je vous prie de
m'excuser par avance je serai moi même
un tout petit peu longue donc à
l'article 12 la commission a souhaité
répondre à une préoccupation locale
forte puisque plus des 90 % des 1800
élus locaux qui ont répondu à notre
consultation qui a été lancée donc par
le sénat sur le projet de loi climat et
résilience estime pertinent de
généraliser une consigne pour ré emploi
sur le vert nous devons une semble
écouter cette demande de nos élus locaux
en charge de service public de gestion
des déchets
pour autant nous avons souhaité avancer
sur la question du réemploi avec
pragmatisme puisque j'entends toutes les
questions et toutes les
les interrogations que vous pouvez avoir
sur les bancs de cette assemblée et est
aussi dans le respect évidemment des
différentes filières économiques que
j'ai eu moi-même en contact et qui nous
ont appelé à plusieurs reprises nous
avons donc adopté un amendement
prévoyant qu'une évaluation de la
pertinence économique et environnemental
de la consigne envers devra être réalisé
avant 2023
en permettant d'identifier plus finement
les secteurs et emballages qui devront
faire l'objet d'un dispositif de
consignes cette évaluation devra
permettre d'accompagner la menthe la
montée en puissance du réemploi
l'amendement adopté en commission
prévoit d'autre part que soient définies
par décret une trajectoire d'évolution
de la proportion minimale d'emballages
en verre réemployer à mettre sur le
marché annuellement en france
il s'agit là de répondre à la demande
forte de nos élus locaux en faveur du
développement du réemploi sur le vert
tout en donnant de la visibilité aux
mets ta sur le marché et en permettant
un développement différenciée selon les
filières
j'insiste là dessus parce que je crois
qu'il y avait une crainte chez certains
d'entre vous autour de 7
je dirai ce pot commun dans lequel on
mettrait en fait l'équivalent de tous
leurs un emploi c'est une position
que je pense être très équilibré qui se
place dans la continuité ce que nous
avons fait dans le cadre de la loi à gec
pour clarifier la rédaction adoptée en
commission et pour répondre à la
préoccupation légitimes soulevées par
plusieurs amendements déposés à l'alinéa
je vous ai proposé un amendement de
clarification visant à préciser que le
décret définissant la trajectoire
d'évolution de la proportion minimale
d'emballages en verre est employé à
mettre sur le marché
annuellement en france ne pourra être
prise qu'après l'évaluation
environnementale et économique de
l'observatoire pour le réemploi et la
réutilisation
donc avis défavorable aux amendements de
suppression le j'espère ne pas me
tromper dans les numéros le 226 le66 le
123 le 224 et le 952
car pour partie satisfaits par
l'amendement de clarification que je
vous ai proposé qui est le 2022 1222 que
je vous ai présenté tout à l'heure je
suis également défavorable aux 599 771
et 300 qui vise à accroître les
objectifs de mise sur le marché
d'emballage réemployer la loi g prévoit
déjà des objectifs de mise sur le marché
d'emballage réemployer 5% en 2023 et 10%
de l'avis de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes ces objectifs sont déjà très
ambitieux il ne me semble donc pas
pertinent de les accroître
par ailleurs je suis défavorable aux
amendements prévoyant d'exclure les
boissons alcoolisées de la trajectoire
de mise sur le marché d'emballage
réemployer anvers
l'évaluation des dispositifs de
consignes pour l'observatoire du
réemploi et de la réutilisation
permettra de toute manière de cibler
précisément les filières privilégiée
dans le développement de la consigne or
le décret fixant la trajectoire demi sur
le maché d'emballage réemployer envers
prévues par cet article 12
n'interviendra qu'après cette évaluation
le dispositif est donc suffisamment
sécurisé pour les producteurs de
boissons alcoolisées donc avis
défavorable aussi 172,67 124 953 et 1785
également avis défavorable au 1366 qui
étend l'observatoire de la réutilisation
en fait confie des missions
supplémentaires à l'observatoire de la
réutilisation et dieu du réemploi à la
réparation je pense qu'il aura
suffisamment de mission et de tâches de
toute façon pour ne pas les alourdir
ensuite avis défavorable pour le 225
pour les mêmes raisons que précédemment
évoqué le retour à la rédaction de
l'assemblée nationale constituerait un
recul d'un point de vue environnemental
par rapport à ce que nous avions voté
dans cette assemblée
ensuite avis défavorable au 1767
l'évaluation de la consigne pour l
emploi sur les emballages en verre doit
être la plus large possible il ne semble
pas opportun de les limiter aux seuls
emballages de poids de boissons comme le
prévoit cet amendement enfin avis
favorable au 1080 18 je ne sais pas s'il
était défendu celui ci j'ai un doute une
meilleure association des professions
concernées peut contribuer à étudier
plus finement les filets à pour
lesquelles il est pertinent
économiquement et environnementalement
de mettre en place des systèmes de
consignes pourrait emplois sur le vel
sur le verre pardon et celles pour
lesquelles ce n'est pas le cas voilà mes
chers collègues et
différents avis qui ont été mis sur ces
amendements je crois qu'il y en avait 18
donc j'étais un tout petit peu long je
vous prie de m'excuser oui madame la
rapporte à si vous pouviez ne pas ne pas
de défendre on va dire ceux qui ont déjà
pas été pris parce que les sénateurs ne
sont absents parce que c'est un peu
difficile dans toute la masse de
retrouver donc normalement pour moi vous
êtes défavorable à tous sauf le vôtre et
le dernier le 1098
on est d'accord merci beaucoup excusez
moi madame la mini c'est à vous pour
avis du gouvernement
je vous en prie madame la présidente
merci je voulais répondre à quelques
arguments que j'ai entendus pour pour
essayer d'éclairer un petit peu les
débats
d'abord j'ai entendu des arguments sur
l'intérêt de réemployer les bouteilles
en verre au regard du recyclage en
disant il ya quand même beaucoup de
bouteilles en verre qui sont recyclés et
donc
pourquoi finalement perdre un peu du
temps de l'énergie à réemployer des
bouteilles en fait on a de nombreuses
études en acv sur les systèmes existants
qui démontre l'intérêt environnemental
du réemploi l'impact environnemental des
dispositifs de réemploi dépend de
plusieurs facteurs des principaux étant
le taux de réutilisation du contenu les
distances et les modes de transport le
taux de recyclage de l'emballage à usage
unique avec lequel ces dispositifs sont
comparés dans le cas de la bouteille en
verre c'est l'étape de fabrication
d'emballages qui est la plus impactante
d'un point de vue environnemental les
impacts proviennent très majoritairement
de la production du verre ainsi une
bouteille en verre qui est réemployer à
un meilleur bilan environnemental qu'une
bouteille en verre recyclé dès les
premières réutilisation et une étude de
l'ademe qui date de 2010 huit ans et qui
a analysé dispositif de réemploi du
verre conclu que sur tous les
indicateurs et dispositifs étudier le
système avec réemploi à une performance
environnementale supérieure ou égale au
système sans réemploi réutilisation il y
avait en france aussi une étude l'étude
de roche date qui est un peu plus ancien
qui date de 2009 qui conclut que le
réemploi des bouteilles en verre dans le
contexte de la brasserie meteor permet
de consommer 76 % d'énergie primaire en
moi d'émettre 79% émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en moins de consommer 33
pour soi % d'eau en moins par rapport au
recyclage
sachant que le nombre de réutilisation
de la bouteille et de 20 avec une
distance de distribution moyenne de 260
kilomètres les brasserie meteor aide
réemploi 60% de leurs bouteilles
ce qui est ce qui est très intéressant
et ils le font depuis très longtemps et
ça se passe
a priori très bien sûr la fameuse
distance aussi de transport des 200 km
puisqu'il m'a été objecter que la
réflexion j'avais fait tout à l'heure et
une réflexion pour l'étranger les
distances de transport sont un paramètre
évidemment qui joue un rôle clé dans la
performance environnementale des
dispositifs de réemploi mais ce n'est
pas le seul paramètre le taux de
réemploi du contenant et de tout
recyclage de l'emballage de l'emballage
à usage unique avec lequel de
dispositifs de consignes pour est ample
et comparer sont les autres principaux
paramètres qui influent sur la
performance environnementale des
dispositifs donc pour un même nombre de
cycles de réemploi plus les distances de
transport vont être courtes plus
l'impact environnemental des dispositifs
de consignes va être réduit quelque part
c'est un peu cul cqfd
j'ai tendance à dire on entend souvent
qu'au delà de 200 km le bilan
environnemental du réemploi par rapport
au recyclage serait négatif ce chiffre
vient d'un cas particulier à étudier
dans une étude de l'ademe datant de 2018
et ne peut absolument pas être
généralisée à tous les dispositifs de
consignes pour et emploi d'autant que
certains dispositifs plus optimisée
aboutissent à des ré emploi des
résultats pardon différents l'étude de
roche dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure qui compare à la bouteille de
bière réemployables à celle à usage
unique permet de conclure que pour des
distances de transport de 800 kilomètres
aller-retour est dit réutilisation de la
bouteille le ratio reste toujours
favorable au réemploi vous faut vraiment
regarder au cas par cas
vraiment
et donc ce que ce que je voulais dire
par là c'est que on ne peut pas se
permettre de mettre en place des
dispositifs sans avoir travaillé un
petit peu au cas par cas pour vérifier
là où il est utile et là où il ne l'est
pas et c'est pourquoi je pense que le
dispositif qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale complétée par la
commission et qui est utilement
d'ailleurs complété par l'amendement
près 2222 de madame de sidra à coquelles
je mettrais un avis favorable permet
justement de d'avoir cette méthode cette
méthodologie qui permettra de faire du
réemploi quand sites intéressants et de
ne pas en faire quand ce n'est pas un
thé quand ce n'est pas intéressant je
voulais juste rajouter un point sur sur
l'aspect économique qui est important
pour les producteurs qui pratiquent le
réemploi depuis plusieurs années les
dispositifs de collecte et de lavage
sont aujourd'hui rentable donc là je
parle de ceux qui le font déjà
ce sont des dispositifs amortis depuis
plusieurs années dont les coûts de
transport sont inclus dans les
transports réalisés pour les livraisons
et une fois des investissements initiaux
puisqu'il faut des investissements
initiaux amorti et les circuits
logistiques optimiser les systèmes de
réemploi tendent à être moins coûteux
que l' usage unique
voilà les quelques éléments que je
souhaitais partager avec vous avant de
vous dire donc que j'émets un avis
favorable à l'amendement de madame de
cidre actes en khl 2222
j'émettrais également un avis de sagesse
sur le 225 de madame delattre qui qui
souhaitent rétablir les une partie de la
rédaction de l'article 12 voté à
l'assemblée nationale sur les modalités
d'évaluation préalable à la mise en
place d'une consignes des emballages en
verre
en dehors de ces deux amendements
j'émettrais un avis défavorable à tous
les autres dont je vais mettre au foie
l'amendement 226 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable
la commission et du gouvernement qui a
eu les retirer merci quatre amendements
identiques le 66 le 123 le 224 et le 952
qui ont reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
e
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
ils sont adoptés jusqu'au 17 juin
alors donc le 771 tombe 300 tombes 60
524 953 et 1785 tombe s'il vous plaît un
tout petit peu de silence merci beaucoup
l'amendement 1366 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient pas adopté l'amendement
225 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui pour le 225 qui et
contre qui s'abstient ne pas adopter la
maman 1098 qui a reçu un avis favorable
de la commission est défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour cet amendement
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est donc
adopté
[Musique]